こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん！
ボンボンTVの、よっち
ご存知でしょうか
彼はですね
たまに僕んちに遊びに来てるんですけども
今やもうボンボンTVをしきるね
こっボスみたいな感じになってて
よっちはですね　その
ボンボンTVのメンバーでありながらも
ＵＵＵＭの社員さんなので
まあ僕の１個下の後輩で
富山県も同じ出身なんで
こうなんか
僕のことリスペクトしてくれてるんですよ、凄く。
はじめさーん　はじめさーん
ﾌﾞﾌｩｩｯ
すごい僕のことリスペクトしてくれる
なんかこう
はじめさんみたいなYouTuberになりたいです。
みたいなことよく言ってくれてて
非常に嬉しいですけどもぉ！
その気持ちは本物なのか
その僕に対するリスペクト精神は
本物なのかって言うのを
僕はちょっと今回確かめようかと思いまして
インターネットで欠かせない存在
それは何かわかりますか？
(ﾊﾟﾁﾝｯ！)　そう！
アンチです。
ネットのどの世界にも
YouTubeじゃなくてもね
もうどこにもアンチというものはいるんですよ
ネットはね顔を隠してね
好きなこと言えるから
そのー　思ってもないこと言ってみたり
気に食わない人がいたら
とりあえず暴言を吐いてみたりする人たちがたっくさんいるんですけども
僕にももちろんいると思うんですよ　アンチが
今回はですねー
もしそのアンチが僕の家を特定して
僕んちまで入ってきて
僕を捕まえて　僕をねその拉致して
捕まえてどっか持って行こうとした時に
ＵＵＵＭ社員兼僕の後輩であり
ボンボンTVのリーダーたるよっちは
どう行動するのか今回ちょっと確かめてみようと思います
よっちがもうすぐ家に来るので
よっちと僕が
僕んちの近くのコンビニに「行こう」って
一緒に歩いて僕んちのドアを開けた時に
そこからアンチが２人刃物を持って僕を殺しに
そして捕まえに来た時に
一緒にいたよっちはどう行動するのか
今回は検証してみたいと思います
よっち・・・
べしっ！！
俺を助けてくれ！！
では行こう！
ぐきいい
(カメラに向かって手を振るはじめんの図)
ｼﾞｬｯｼﾞｬｲｼﾞｬｲあんの～？
(自主規制)
(聞き取り不可能)
いや、凄い、マジで凄い事だからｗ
ﾏｼﾞｯ
ﾅﾆｯﾅﾆｳｺﾞｶｻﾚﾊﾞ
いやっ、ｳｰ✩
すごいっ
あっ(´・ω・｀)
ｽｺｯ
ｳｪｲｯ
ｳﾜｧｧｧｧｧｧ
ﾌｫｧｧｧｧｧ
ｱｧｧｧｧｧｯ
ｵｲｳｪｲｯ
上着脱げぇｯ
(アンチの声とはじめ＆よっちの悲鳴)
ｵﾏｴﾄｯﾃﾝｼﾞｬﾈｪ
ﾌｫｫｳﾜｧｧ
遂に見つけたぞｫ
ｵﾙｩｱｧｧ！！
うわあああああああ...
ﾔﾀﾞｧ！！
(よっちとアンチの声)
よっち、池田さん呼んで！
ｱｧｧｱｧｧ...
ｳｩｨﾃｨｸﾙじゃないよぉ！！
ｱｧｧｱｧｧｱｧｱｧ...
＿人人人人人人人人人人人人＿
＞ はじめんが誘拐されちゃった＜
￣ Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y￣
Σ(ﾟдﾟlll)えっ！？
どうすんのこれ...
え…どうすんのこれ
えぇ...池田さん？
池田さん！
はじめさんが…
連れて行かれました…
ﾊｧ?
ちょめっちゃ手震えてるやばい
ｱｯｳﾜｳﾜｳﾜ
ｵｫｳﾜｳﾜ
▂▅▇█▓▒░(’ω’)░▒▓█▇▅▂うわあああああああああああああ
(アンチの声とよっちの悲鳴)
えぇ...
ｴｪｯ↑
ガチャン（ドアの閉まる音）
＿人人人人人人人人人人人人＿
＞ 池田さんも誘拐されちゃった＜
￣ Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y￣
えぇ...嘘でしょ？コレ...
え、まじで？
▂▅▇█▓▒░(’ω’)░▒▓█▇▅▂ﾜｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｯ
びっくりした〜
▂▅▇█▓▒░(’ω’)░▒▓█▇▅▂うおあおあぁぁっ
ｱｧうわああああああぁあ
ﾌｫｫｫ↑ｱｧｧｧｯ↑ｗｗｗｗｗ
ｵｫｲ！
ﾊｯﾊｧｯﾊｯ
ｱ゛ｧ゛
ｱ゛ァ゛
ドッキリだいせいこーう！！！！
もぉ～...びっくりした...
というわけで今日はですね
僕がアンチに襲われたら
よっちは助けてくれるのかどうかドッキリでした〜
無理っす...無理っす...ぜっったい...無理...
俺も(ヾﾉ･∀･`)ﾑﾘﾑﾘ
なんだこの曲...いつもと違うぞ...ﾍﾟｯ↑ができないじゃないか..
また見てね！！